this video is sponsored by Skillshare
click the link in the description for
more information a discussion of how to
be a good teacher sounds a little narrow
and probably not very relevant to most
of us
few of us want to be a school teacher
instructing children in some narrow
academic subject or other which is what
we overwhelmingly associate with the
word teacher the person in a rather
frayed jacket in front of the class the
type who may have bored us Richard for
long stretches in our early years
however teaching is far from being
something that we only need to learn if
we're contemplating a career in
education considered properly teaching
by which we mean the vital business of
getting an important idea from one mind
into another is one of the most crucial
life skills that any of us ever requires
it's vital in any relationship office or
family will ever belong to every one of
us whatever our occupation needs to
become a good teacher for our lives
constantly require us to deliver crucial
information with Grace and effectiveness
into the deep minds of others we can
admit quite candidly that most of us
have probably started off by being quite
bad teachers this is nothing to be
ashamed of like most things teaching can
and must be learnt what then are some of
the prerequisites of the good teacher
here is a start to the list the good
teacher never blames another person for
not already knowing it seems paradoxical
once it's pointed out but the truth is
we often get very annoyed by the fact
that another person doesn't know
something yet even though we've never
actually told them what this might be
certain ideas can seem so important to
us we simply can't imagine that others
don't already know them we suspect they
may be deliberately upsetting us by
pretending not to have a clue
this attitude makes it unlikely that
what we actually have to teach will make
its way successfully into the unfort
not other person's head good teaching
starts with the idea that ignorance is
not a defect of the individual we're
instructing it's the consequence of
never having been properly taught so the
fault rightly really only ever belongs
with the people who haven't done enough
to get the needed ideas into other's
heads in other words with you to good
teachers don't get angry the more we
need other people to know something the
less we may be able to secure the calm
frame of mind which is indispensable if
we're to have any chance of conveying it
to them effectively the possibility that
they won't quickly understand something
that matters immensely to us can drive
us into an agitated fury which is the
very worst state in which to conduct any
lesson by the time we've started to
insult our so-called pupil to call them
a blockhead or a fool the lesson is
quite plainly over no one has ever
learned anything under conditions of
humiliation paradoxically the best sort
of teachers can bear the possibility
that what they have to teach will not be
understood it is this slightly detached
slightly pessimistic approach that
stands the best chance of generating the
relaxed frame of mind essential to
successful pedagogy three good teachers
can admit that they don't know lots of
things it's pretty humiliating to be in
the learning position someone else has
information that you don't that can be
so irritating the person learning may
just shut their ears and hate the
alleged superiority of the one in the
teaching role that's why another
fundamental skill of the good teacher is
to admit that they are in most areas of
life pretty ignorant and stupid
this might seem to undermine their
authority far from it it creates an
atmosphere of goodwill and modesty which
puts the pupil at ease they might not
know this particular thing that's being
taught but they are overall not inferior
to the teacher and so they can dare to
face up to their ignorance in a given
area
and submit to the discipline of having
it nicely corrected for good teachers
pick their moments as bad teachers we
tend attack Li to try to teach a lesson
at the moment the problem arises rather
than selecting a time when it's most
likely to be attended to properly crises
aren't the best times for a lesson we
might have to wait a long time
three days after an argument for example
in order to pick just the opportunity to
deal with its underlying dynamics when
our partner is stacking the dishwasher
and humming a song might be the wisest
moment cheerfully and innocently to
refer back to something that truly
maddened us a little while back but over
which we were at the time sagely silent
as we're beginning to see the more
desperate we feel inside the less likely
we are to get through to others
effectively it's deeply unfortunate that
we typically end up addressing the most
delicate and complex teaching tasks just
when we feel most irritated and
distressed we suffer from a panic
feeling that if we don't jump on this
right now an issue is going to go on and
on unchecked forever precisely not we
should be more confident that not
jumping on an issue is what is in fact
going to allow us to fix it properly a
little way down the line five good
teachers are also good students
good teachers know that everyone has a
lot to learn and everyone has something
important to teach to others we should
never get incensed if someone is trying
to teach us something and snap back I
want you to like me just as I am only a
perfect being would be committed to
remaining just as they are for all the
rest of us good learning and teaching
are the only ways we'll ever be able to
progress and grow and that's why we
should welcome them as the gifts they
truly are
we partnered with Skillshare today as it
is a fantastic starting point for anyone
also looking to learn new skills and
they have given us an amazing offer to
pass on to you a premium membership
gives you unlimited access to all
courses and usually starts at around $10
a month but the first 1,000 people to
sign up at the first link in the
description will get their first two
months for just 99 cents if you haven't
heard of Skillshare before it's home to
thousands of classes in graphic design
animation web development music
photography design and more you can
start learning how to do just about
anything in two months you could easily
learn the skills you need to start a new
hobby or business is there a project
that you've been dreaming of completing
but just aren't sure if you have the
skills to do it why not start right now
and sign up to skill share using the
link below you have nothing to lose and
potentially valuable life skills to gain
and you would be helping out our channel
to take a look at the link for more
information